the Gilbert u-238 atomic energy lab this
atomic energy lab was designed to help
children learn how to make nuclear
weapons
seriously sometimes kids toys can have
adult consequences when you were a kid
did you ever wish for a toy that seemed
a little too dangerous
you'll shoot your eye out kid
from long darts to Easy Bake Ovens it
seems a toy makers secretly want to kill
you they've invented toy weapons deadly
dolls and lab kits containing Asbestos
and even uranium so let's put on our
lawyer hat and look at some of the most
dangerous toys that have ever been
invented and discuss how legal or
illegal they were now there was a time
when CSI was the most popular TV show in
the world the show aired at 10 pm and
obviously was geared towards and mostly
popular with adults but the thing is why
monetize just adults when you can also
monetize children
so the executives at CBS capitalized on
the popularity of CSI by giving Planet
toys a license to make CSI themed toys
the company passed on the obvious
choices sunglasses for David Caruso one
of these
that instead came up with two
fingerprint kits for kids who shouldn't
be watching the show anyway but this
quickly turned into a fiasco when tests
conducted by the asbestos disease
awareness organization reveal that the
kits contained white powder that
consisted of seven percent tremolite one
of the most dangerous forms of asbestos
asbestos is a potent carcinogen in any
form but it poses the greatest health
risk but it is in tiny particulates
which are allowed to become airborne and
easily enter the body this is precisely
the form that it took in the CSI
forensics kit when confronted with the
test results planted toys told retailers
to stop sales of the CSI exam kit
however the company refused to stop
selling the CSI lab kit which contained
the same fingerprint powder and it
refused to voluntarily recall either of
the products as you might have guessed
this didn't end well for Planet toys
which filed for Chapter 7 bankruptcy in
2009 declaring liabilities of at least
10 million uh Chapter 7 bankruptcy is
the kind of bankruptcy where there's no
reorganization or managing of debts the
company just gives up a good idea to
quit while you're ahead instead of
losing a bunch of money and seeing the
mesotheliomic consequences of your
actions 40 years down the line and not
surprisingly CBS later settled a class
action lawsuit brought by the people who
had purchased those kits now that takes
us to the swing wing
the swing Wing was invented by an out of
work chiropractor no that's not a joke
now how do you think your neck would
feel after five minutes of this motion
look at this kid go
this toy consists of a ribbon with
weighted balls attached to it which fits
around a child's head kind of like a
cranial weed whacker now I can't imagine
what could go wrong with a rope that's
being swung around a child's neck look
elephants and monkeys enjoy watching
kids use it which is an unorthodox way
to Market a toy also maybe those
elephants and monkeys are just hungry
and waiting for kids to commit their own
sort of Darwin Award not surprisingly
the swing Wing was pulled from shelves
because many kids who played with the
toy suffered cerebral hemorrhages and
neck injuries who would have predicted
that whipping your head back and forth
with weighted balls would be bad for you
now the best-selling toy for boys in
1964 was the Johnny Seven one-man Army
your squad is ready for you to lead them
through with Johnny Seven the one-man
army gun I released during the Cold War
this toy had everything kids needed to
survive their own Red Dawn including a
grenade launcher an anti-armor gun an
anti-tank rocket and an anti-bunker
missile a Tommy Gun and the
semi-automatic pistol that fired caps
with a rifle with 12 bullets when fully
deployed this toy was three feet long
and weighed four pounds four pounds of
pure military-grade testosterone
detective Goran demonstrated all seven
weapons on an episode of Law and Order
Criminal Intent seven weapons in one
grenade launcher
anti-tank rocket
armor-piercing shell
anti-bunker missile machine gun repeater
rifle
cap gun
I definitely want one also I support
military interventionism now that's
weird but this toy is legendary Captain
Kangaroo banned ads for the Johnny Seven
one-man Army from his show because he
didn't want to promote violence that of
course just made it even cooler and it's
become a kind of Holy Grail for toy
collectors it can even be yours for the
low low price of 450 on eBay with sixty
dollars for shipping Freedom Aid free
baby so is it illegal to sell a toy like
this well generally not the 1970s
consumer Advocates petitioned the US
consumer product safety commission to
regulate or ban toy guns the federal
government considered it for years but
eventually agreed to allow toy makers to
create their own list of voluntary
standards these standards focus on
warning labels and clear instructions
but leave the design of the toys largely
up to the manufacturer today there's
just one federal law regulating toy guns
15 USC section 5001 which requires toy
guns to have a blaze orange plug on the
muzzle to distinguish toy guns from the
real thing this law was passed in 1986
and it applies retroactive to all toys
manufactured designed and produced since
1898 however the law does not stop the
end user from modifying the weapon so
today the Johnny 7 one-man Army would be
illegal unless they painted the muzzle
orange but don't come crying to me if
the police shoot your children as a
result I'm just kidding the police will
shoot your children anyway it only takes
us from guns to vegetables developed in
1978 by Xavier Roberts a Cabbage Patch
Kids dolls were all the rage in the
1980s and came in many variations Hasbro
bought the rights to the brand and
started producing a line of Cabbage
Patch Kids with various functions
entered 1995 snack time kids a munching
and chewing doll which sounds like a
nightmare and for hundreds or thousands
of kids it probably did inspire a few
nightmares as you can see the dolls had
moving mouths and let kids feed these
fat dolls with plastic snacks after the
kids fed the doll the food was deposited
into a backpack obviously this has all
the Hallmarks of a bad idea what kid
would stop with the plastic French fries
and gum and why not try feeding the
doll's real food if parents weren't
paying attention and any food got stuck
the food just stayed there until it
rotted but that wasn't the biggest
problem with these dolls the biggest
problem was that these snack time
Cabbage Patch Kids had a taste for human
flesh or at least hair
and the bigger problem was that the doll
didn't have an on or an off switch the
mouth operated by having rollers move
the food and if the food kept on coming
the rollers kept on moving this meant
that kids got their hair caught in a
doll's mouth which was designed to keep
rolling up until whatever it bid ended
up in the backpack for some kids that
meant being trapped for up to 30 minutes
while their parents dismantled the doll
by chopping his head off and then
searching the body cavity for the
batteries hundreds of irate parents
complained and Mattel voluntarily
recalled the toys and paid 40 refunds to
500 000 people who purchased this
cannibal Cabbage Patch doll that takes
us to Sky Dancers Sky Dancers look
innocent enough these are dolls that can
fly
really fly I just pull the string and
watch them soar like helicopters
children love them and they were popular
enough to stay on the market from 1994
until the turn of the century when the
US government declared them too
dangerous the US consumer product safety
commission is charged with protecting
the public from unreasonable risks of
injury or death associated with the use
of thousands of types of consumer
products and according to the cpsc sky
dancers had a propensity to fly and go
in unpredictable directions causing all
kinds of harm and in fact when I was a
kid I busted open my lip with a similar
product why because when you pull the
string you naturally put your face
directly in front of the spinning death
helicopters and the hard plastic that
was used for the wings could do some
real damage and the toy company received
170 reports that the dolls Were Striking
children and adults resulting in 150
reports of injuries injuries reported
included eye injuries including scratch
corneas and incidents of temporary
blindness broken teeth mild concussion a
broken rib and facial lacerations that
required stitches but all's well that
ends well when the cpsc ordered recall
of 8.9 million Sky Dancers now what are
the best ways to aggravate parents is to
sell a toy that is both noisy and
dangerous and that's just what toy
makers achieved with clackers a kid
version of bolus a weapon that
Argentinian Gauchos used to hunt the new
original Miracle crackers won't shatter
even if you use both hands try stereo
cracking with unbreakable Miracle
crackers bolus our throwing Weapon made
of weights on the end of interconnected
cords in fact the only real difference
between clackers and the deadly bolus is
that clackers are shorter and not made
of wood just like attorney Tom
someday you'll be a real boy now rather
than throwing them and animals to tangle
up their legs kids were supposed to
swing the clackers until they made an
ear splitting noise
what could possibly go wrong well they
violate Legal Eagles rule number one for
kids toys anything that can be used as a
weapon will be used as a weapon now the
first clackers appeared in the late 60s
and they were made from tempered glass
which contrary to the marketing about
being unbreakable would eventually
shatter pelting users with shards of
glass eventually the US government
classified clackers as a mechanical
hazard in the court case and worst epic
rap battle of history United States
versus article consisting of 50 000
cardboard boxes more or less each
containing one pair of clacker balls now
this case became famous because people
were amused by the fact that the
government seemed to have sued the
clacker balls and the boxes that they
were contained in themselves but that's
because the seizure was an exercise of
jurisdiction in rem jurisdiction in rem
is a legal term describing the power a
court May exercise over property it
assumes that the property or status is
the primary object of the action classic
cases involving jurisdiction in rem
include United States versus one
Tyrannosaurus Batar skeleton South
Dakota vs 15 pounded cats and one 1958
Plymouth Sedan versus Pennsylvania in
the case of the clackers the United
States Marshals seized a shipment of
clacker balls in the Ace Novelty Company
filed a complaint against forfeiture
arguing that the shipment was not a
banned Hazard as defined by the federal
hazardous Substances Act the government
argued that the clackers were hazardous
as the term was defined in 16 CFR
1500.18 which bans toys presenting a
mechanical Hazard and while the ace
Novelty Company argued that there was an
exception the court sided with the U.S
government and eventually banned the
bolus I mean uh children's toy look for
this package
now just about everyone is familiar with
the slip and slide staple of the summer
okay everybody come outside
the southern side was invented by Robert
carrier after watching his son
deliberately slide across wet concrete
and carpet in the garage carrier was an
upholster who worked with a company that
produced boat seats so he borrowed a
50-foot roll of nagahide installed a
hose and invented one of the most iconic
summer toys carrier took his invention
to the wamo company which was behind the
popular toys like the Frisbee and the
hula hoop naugahyde was replaced with
plastic and the toy went on sale in
1961. now obviously everyone loved it
and initially there were few injuries
reported but the slip and slide soon
encountered a problem kids loved it so
much that adults wanted to join in
adults who maybe had a few too many cans
of lawsuit juice
lawsuit juice it's not beer we swear
it's totally just beer but the slip and
slide was not designed for adults the
instructions said that the product was
designed for children 10 and over and
presumably that didn't include youthful
grown-ups in in 1987 a 34 year old man
broke his neck and was paralyzed after
using a slip and slide a jury decided
that slip and slide was defective and
unreasonably dangerous and gave the
plaintiff over 12 million dollars in
1988 at University of Central Florida
student also broke his neck on the slide
he won his lawsuit as well and the toy
company took the slip and slide off the
market eventually in 1993 the U.S
consumer product safety commission
issued a recall notice and the slipping
slide was slip and shelled fortunately
for kids the slip inside has been given
a new life you can buy a new one
complete with a warning that is only
safe for kids 12 and over so to all of
you kids and adults out there please
slip and slide responsibly or don't I'm
not your parent though I can represent
you in a lawsuit over a horrific injury
[Music]
now if these toys aren't scary enough
for you then you might be interested in
the Gilbert u-238 atomic energy lab this
set was created by Alfred Carlton
Gilbert who was also the inventor of the
erector set his atomic energy lab was
designed to help children learn how to
make nuclear weapons no uh seriously
this toy actually included uranium
samples it came with four glass jars
containing natural uranium bearing ore
samples the goal was for kids to learn
how to create and watch nuclear and
chemical reactions using radioactive
materials obviously how else are you
gonna do it a Gilbert insisted this was
a safe toy as long as you didn't break
the seals on the uranium samples you
know how kids don't break the toys that
they're given luckily the lab included a
real geiger counter an electroscope a
Wilson Cloud chamber and some low-level
radiation sources including zinc
polonium and ruthenium Isotopes labeled
alpha beta and gamma depending on which
particular radiation particles they
emitted now the product catalog explains
that the atomic reactions are beautiful
to watch they're project regularly
beautiful once you've had the kid long
enough to grow a third eyeball and
despite the hype this toy never caught
on in fewer than 5000 kits were ever
sold it cost 47 in 1950s which was the
equivalent of at least 550 today now the
atomic energy lab was meant to make kids
smarter but it would have only resulted
in kids getting a third arm but one
non-radioactive way for kids and adults
to actually learn about mathematics and
Sciences through today's sponsor
brilliant brilliant is an online
learning platform for stem that replaces
lecture videos with Hands-On interactive
lessons brilliant is for Curious
Learners both young and old professional
and inexperienced you quickly learn to
Ace your high school exams college math
courses or just learn stuff that you
always wanted to learn for example if
the makers of these toys had taken
Brilliance logic course maybe they would
have known that it was a crazy idea to
create all of these insanely dangerous
toys because Brilliance logic courses
cover liar and Truth teller riddles
logical fallacies machine logic and even
strategic game theory and logic is a
crucial skill that lawyers need every
day especially when they're suing toy
manufacturers and I also really enjoyed
Brilliance data science foundations
course which starts with probability
fundamentals and builds up to using data
predictions experimentation and neural
networks but the kind of thing where you
learn to understand an introduction of
probability applied statistics and
statistics fundamentals because
brilliant lets you learn by doing rather
than listening to hours of boring
lectures learning through doing is
scientifically proven to be the most
effective way to master any new skill
the courses have storytelling
interactive challenges and problems to
solve now you can sign up and start
learning for free today by going to
brilliant.org legaleagle or click on the
link that's on screen right now and the
first 200 people to sign up will also
get 20 off their annual subscription so
by clicking on the link below you'll get
20 off your subscription to brilliant
plus clicking that link really helps out
this Channel and after that click on
this box over here for more legal eagle
or I'll see you in court